الات فرز الحبوب تعمل بكل طاقتها اذنا
ببدا موسم حصاد الارز الحساوي الذي انطلق
في محافظه الاحساء في المنطقه الشرقيه
زكي السالم فتح ابواب مزرعته لاستقبال
الجميع سواء من محبي الارز او العيش
الحساوي او ممن يريدون التعرف على هذا
المنتج التراثي
1900 سنه قلت
لابد اني احط كل هواي فهذا المنتج فاخذت
هذا المساحه فالحمد لله صار الانتاج غزير
محاوله استزراع العيش الحساوي خارج
السعوديه لم تكن موفقه
بالصين
يقول لي الاحسائيين لكل مواطن سعودي يفتخر
ان هذا المنتج
جرب في دول العالم ولا نجح الا في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
بلونه الاحمر وقيمته الغذائيه العاليه حيث
يحتوي على فوائد صحيه كبيره من الحديد
وهذا ما اكتشفه زوار مزرعه السالم الذي
حارس ان يكرم ضيوفه
يحتاج هذا النوع من المحاصيل الى عنايه
خاصه لان زراعته تبدا في فصل الصيف
من المساحه اللي انت تزرعها 40 يوم بعدين
نشيلها
ننجفه وبعدين نوديه في الاماكن الثانيه
يضافه الى اسلام هذا المنتج الزراعي في
الحفاظ على الموروث الثقافي السعودي فانه
من خلال الاستثمار فيه وتطوير تقنيه
زراعته يساهم القطاع الخاص في رؤيه 2030